the clark county school district
transition plan
seems to be creating more questions and
answers among educators and families
now the district released this 205 page
document last night
the proposal details how to bring staff
and students back to campus safely
with a hybrid model that's when students
attend class in person
two days and continue distance learning
at home the other three days
while it begins the process to bring
students back some remain
uncertain about the logistics it feels
like there was not
a very robust conversation with any
educators
because we've already found so many
holes in it things they haven't really
thought through
it's brought up so many questions some
questions include how educators may
teach students in person and online at
the same time
ccsd is also offering families the
choice to continue
full-time distance education we should
point out many private charter and
catholic schools
are doing hybrid learning and have been
for months we asked you on twitter do
you think ccsd has created a good return
plan
35 percent say yes 65 percent
say no